because the money is just all money to
me in my opinion
and i say this all the time i hope
everybody gets some money so you can see
that
it doesn't do anything but just makes
the
things that you can't control easier to
deal with money is like uh
like a moon bounce kinda you know i mean
like in life
we fall down and we ain't got no money
when you fall down you hitting the
concrete
straight concrete scraping your knees
bust your head open
you know what i mean bleeding you got to
lick your wounds and get up and you limp
into the next thing
but the more money you get now your moon
belt starts to blow up so when you fall
now you don't hit the concrete you just
bounce back up
so that's all it does it just allows you
to be able to
buy some [ __ ] that you want and not have
the things that you can't control that
life is going to give you cause you to
just break down you know i mean i
remember when my car used to break down
that [ __ ] used to stress me out because
it's like damn now i got to come up with
900
to get some ball bearings when my rent
is due
like what the [ __ ] am i going to do
that's what money does
the stress it eliminates that aspect but
the more you get
then you just go into a different
bracket of stress so all you're doing is
just blowing up your mattress
and blowing up your your moon bounce
rather so when you know you
you fall down or you bump your head or
somebody comes it's
just a cushion but the real success
comes from the view
it comes from what you get to see from
your work
like i didn't know that this part of the
world existed
before i got to this point and money
can't
buy you that like money can't buy you
the experiences that you have when you
really work towards your goal
like i've had people who i grew up
just idolizing walk up and say my name
to me before i can even open my mouth
chico what's up with you man there's no
amount of money that can buy that
that view is what it's about so it's
like once you figure those things out
and once you start to put forth for
effort then that's what the universe
will give you if you're really genuine
and like i said in my opinion i really
believe if you're not hurting yourself
knowingly or hurting anybody else
knowingly everything that you do is
going to gone to you
some type of result yeah i'm at a point
now in my career where it's
the the money is becoming a little bit
more
of like a factor and maybe a motivator
just for the sheer fact of just wanting
to start reinvesting it
into everything i'm doing to start doing
what i'm doing but just
at a higher level let me ask you this
question do you come from
the money no no no no podunk
like i look purebred but i'm in bread
and i got it yeah yeah oh really so yeah
where are you from originally uh
somerville georgia somerville georgia
yeah yeah okay
someville someville sunville some villa
some villa
some ville somewhere yeah yeah someville
georgia parents
educators like i come from like um like
a connected and strong background in
terms of a service background you know
but yeah i don't come from money or
anything like that okay but to even that
like one thing about financial
[Music]
status is that you know most of us and
then when i say us
i mean black people have never had
anything so it's one thing to get some
money
but what you're going to do with it when
you get it because getting it is a whole
lot easier than keeping it
you know i mean to get it you can get
some money but how you going to keep it
and it's a whole nother journey that you
have to take to learn
something that you've never had before
it's like if i
you know uh if you look at it like this
and for some reason people don't equate
it in their minds like this but i do but
if i walk into a judo class today
i'm gonna get the [ __ ] beat out of me
i'm gonna get tossed around
and beat up because i don't know what to
do
i have to learn what to do money is the
same way
if you walk into some money today you're
probably gonna get tossed around
and get the [ __ ] beat out you because
everything that you think
works you have no idea you're just
assuming that it works because you never
had nothing
and you feel like all i need is some
money and that's gonna fix
everything that's going on with me and
it'll fix a lot
until you realize that what you need to
be fixed can't be paid for
you know what i mean so it's like i'm
for
financial stability just because i like
to have the moon balance i like to have
that
ability to be able to eliminate stress
for my loved ones
and i have the problem of worrying about
oh
man this happened or this happened
that's the beauty of financial stability
to me
the beauty of having some money is being
able to
you know if something happens and you
know like
[ __ ] toilet breaks or your sink
breaks down
oh it's gonna be a thousand dollars cool
that just that right exactly that's the
beauty of having money to me
other than that everything else is
something that's way bigger than any
dollar amount can ever give you that's
where the real work comes in to get
those things to
be in a place where you could be on a
bus in australia like i was and had
people walk up to you and
on a metro bus in australia which i
probably didn't have no [ __ ] business
being on anyway but i'm just goofy like
that
walk up and show you a video on their
phone and then watching you
do the work that you do it's amazing
and i'm in australia being paid to be
there to shoot a pilot for a show
that never came out so does that mean
that i'm not successful
because it never came out or am i
successful because i got the opportunity
to go to the
other side of the world and work and get
paid for it
it's all perspective so i don't know how
you look at it when you're scrapping
together how important
is saving versus reinvesting in like
what you're doing
uh you got to invest in yourself you got
to spend money on
you know whatever it is you do but it's
levels to that there's different
elements to that
like i have been a person who has been
in the fashion my whole life just
because i grew up in a house with a lot
of people who will fly
and that's just something that that i
picked up on and that's an investment
into me because i'm a performer
clean and neat that's what my auntie
used to tell me
you can accomplish anything in this
world along as long as you clean and
neat
as long as when somebody sees you they
look like you you can start a
conversation with anyone
and if what you have on and what you
look like
is natural for you like i just got on a
you know black
sweat top and some black shorts but it's
genuine i'm comfortable so when i walk
up and shake your hand
you're not looking at me as a threat
because my energy matches it's clean and
neat
and so you can establish whatever you
want to establish based on that now
that's an investment
into what i do but whatever it is you
got going on you know you got your own
camera your own
right microphones got them
you know what i mean all of that is an
investment into yourself
and saving is
it's important but
everybody always say you should save for
a rainy day and
you know the rainy days and and that's
cool
but what are you going to do
if you got the money and the rain comes
and it doesn't
help you're going to lose it all because
you're going to think you got to spend
it i must not be spending enough
or i must not be saving enough to feel
comfortable you can't have
you can't put your in my opinion you
can't put your
your interest in just having financial
success
because as important as financial
success is especially in america
you got to have some type of peace of
mind to go with that
so you know save some money in order to
invest in yourself but once you invest
in yourself
then you know you'll stop thinking about
it like
the thing that i think getting into
certain circles
does it lets you realize that the
conversation is no longer about money
when i was broke all we talked about was
getting some money
now that i'm not broke anymore we rarely
have conversations amongst
the people that i'm around about money
because
it's not even anything to talk about but
it takes you to get something to learn
that
i'm not saying you know listen to this
and just think that i'm saying you don't
need money you need some money i hope
you get some so you can learn
how to use that within yourself but once
you start to make it
for real and make some money then you
realize that it's really not
something that people discuss when they
don't have to
so the quicker you get out of letting
that be the motivating factor for
whatever it is you do
then the quicker you'll see that you
know it's going to come to you hey hot
brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath the verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips